all right did you guys see this photo  former president george w bush is  sharing pictures of the latest addition  to the Bush family his first grandson  yeah go mr. Bush's daughter Jenna Bush  Hager gave birth to a boy on Friday it  is her third child one photo shows the  Bush clan including his two  granddaughters and his new grandson so  the baby is named Henry Harold Hager  after his dad calling him how they're  calling him how after Jenna's maternal  grandfather she joked that the former  president was upset his grandson was not  named there are a lot of George's though  in that family there's no chance on the  first two grand grandchildren which were  daughter's name one daughter poppy and  the other is Margaret milla milla  nickname yeah yeah which is a great name  that's very exciting the former  president very exciting flat bang thanks  guys